[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt die etwa zeit ist für mich die
schönste zeit im jahr denn da kann man
richtig tolle erste torten backen
heute geht es eine geniale erdbeertorte
in der vergangenheit habe ich auch schon
viele tolle gemacht
die könnt ihr in meiner app nachschauen
oder auf dem blog oder in den
bankbüchern jedenfalls gibt es heute
eine erdbeertorte mit einem schoko tonga
boden und ich mache jetzt erstmal mit
dem boden an und sage ich die zutaten
ja ich nehme dafür vier eier 200 gramm
zucker eine prise salz und etwas tonka
bunker jeweils 200 gramm sonnenblumenöl
und butter milch oder eiern könnt ihr
hier auch nehmen 130 gramm mandeln die
werden gleich gemahlen 260 gramm mehl 2
teelöffel backpulver und 40 gramm cacau
die eier sind schon zimmer war
die kommen jetzt in eine rührschüssel
entweder nimmt jetzt ein handrührgerät
oder so wie ich eine küchenmaschine dann
salz und zucker dazu ist in tonga wanka
staates tonga banker könnt ihr auch
tonkabohne dazu treiben einfach eine
kleine prise so kann man es aber auch
perfekt dosiert also so wie ihr möchtet
gibt nur nie zuviel tonkabohnen abrieb
hinzu
denn tonkabohne ist wie muskatnuss wenn
man zu viel davon nimmt wirkt eben auch
giftig aber eine kleine prise reicht
auch schon weil super ergiebig ist und
jetzt die eier zockermasse für etwa vier
bis fünf minuten cremig rühren und ich
kann in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
mandeln malen und brauche ich auch immer
acht grad besseren also die eisen zimmer
war und hier habe ich ein rahmen statt
butter milch weil es einfach offen war
könnt ihr auch immer super nehmen und
der iran ist auch schon waren den habe
ich in die mikrowelle gestellt als die
man alle zutaten schön die gleiche
temperatur
[Musik]
die eier zucker master ist jetzt schon
so weit ich werde jetzt hier schon mal
einen tortenring einschlagen und
backpapier weil der teig einfach so
flüssig ist den habe ich schon auf 24
zentimeter eingestellt
[Musik]
kann ich hier schon beide flüssigkeiten
dazu geben also öl da nehme ich immer
gerne sonnenblumenöl oder maiskeimöl
oder ihr könnt auch raps übernimmt wobei
rapsöl finde ich beim erhitzen etwas
fisch riecht durch die omega 3 und ex
fed sollten also für mich rechts echt
mega nach fisch dann den iran oder die
butter milch dazugeben kurz einrühren
und jetzt kann ich hier schon mal die
trockenen zutaten vermischen also
einfach zu den mandeln das mehl
dazugeben backpulver und packer und in
schneebesen verrühren und es kommt jetzt
direkt zu den flüssigen zutaten und wird
nur noch kurz ein gerührt also jetzt
nicht mehr lange röhren sondern wirklich
nur noch kurz damit der kuchen nicht
schrecklich wird bei neue heimat
geschrieben hat ich mag speckigen kuchen
heiße gut und gehalt weiter dann hör
halt noch mehr
[Musik]
also ich mach meist vorher dann schon
die maschine aus und rührt und einfach
noch ganz kurz so mit schneebesen durch
damit wirklich nicht überführt wird
das reicht dann schon normalerweise
nicht klopfen an den rand denn ihr wollt
ja nicht die luft die ihr ein gehört
habt wieder raus klopfen
ok jetzt fühle ich die masse schon mal
hier rein kann den kuchen gleich backen
und dann kommt schon die erdbeer creme
dran
[Musik]
hier am rand immer gerne ein bisschen
hoch streichen und sofort backen
[Musik]
während der kuren noch im ofen backen
kann ich schon mal die erdbeer creme zu
bereiten und vorbereiten
dafür nehme ich jetzt auch gefrorene
erdbeeren weil ich die einfach noch da
hatte und die frischen etwa nehme ich
dann für die dekoration und zum renn
schneiden hier freunden werden nämlich
gleich zerkleinert und dadurch entsteht
die erdbeer creme aber da könnt ihr
stadt gefrorenen erdbeeren gerne auch
die frischen nehmen wenn sie schön reif
sind
ok also für die creme brauche ich 400
gramm gefrorene oder frische erdbeeren
500 gramm frischkäse im doppel ram stufe
100 gramm puderzucker etwas modell
extrakt 500 gramm sahne salz steif
schlagen und noch erdbeeren zum klein
schneiden
die erdbeeren habe ich bereits auftauen
lassen die werden jetzt kurz berührt
also egal ob jetzt gefrorene oder
frische erdbeeren einfach kurz pürieren
[Musik]
dann kommt das ganze direkt in einen
topf und hier kann ich jetzt das rpg
einkochen lassen so intensiviert sich
nämlich der geschmack und ich werde
einfach das wasser in den erdbeeren los
sozusagen das jetzt auch kochen und dann
leicht köcheln lassen
das etwa püree dann solange ein kochen
bis die feuchtigkeit fast komplett
verkauft ist also schön ist alles
vorbereiten und später kann man dann
alles gut zusammen fügen dann kann ich
jetzt hier den frischkäse reingeben dann
vanille extrakt dazu puderzucker dazu
[Musik]
und dann kann ich hier den frischkäse
schon mal schön verrühren
einfach kurz cremig rühren
[Musik]
das war es erstmal ich stehe jetzt
einfach kurz alle zutaten also die sahne
und vor allem die creme in den
kühlschrank und wartet wie gesagt
einfach kurz auf die ad werben die
erdbeeren sind jetzt wunderbar
eingekocht also es fast keine
flüssigkeit mehr da ist eine richtig
dicke passte jetzt geworden also ein
dickes püriert das würde ich jetzt hier
nochmal um damit es schön abkühlen kann
denn bevor das nicht kalt das kann ich
nicht weitermachen als ich jetzt
umfüllen richtig kühlschrank kalt
abkühlen lassen ich lasse natürlich
vorher auf zimmertemperatur erstmal
kommen stellt dann den kühlschrank und
dann geht es gleich weiter
[Musik]
jetzt ist dass apple schon kalt und ich
kann es jetzt hier direkt so gefragt
dazu geben zum frischkäse das zu ok ja
ich wollte ursprünglich eine quarkcreme
machen und dann habe ich mich doch dazu
entschlossen der frischkäse grimm zu
machen jetzt habe ich ständig krank im
kopf hast du denn nicht im kopf ich bin
heute irgendwie nebenbei spur
da kommt jetzt an einer party zu
[Musik]
kurz verrühren
man nimmt immer ein teelöffel salz pro
100 milliliter oder 100 gramm asse und
ich habe jetzt einfach für die erdbeeren
noch mal zwei telefonaktion also
zusätzlich zum spricht hier langsam die
sahne ein timer darauf achten war es ist
immer noch frisch aber jetzt richtig
langsam die sahne ein und da immer
darauf achten dass die schön kalt und
jetzt nochmal seiner partei ein und
richtig schön schreibt schlagen
[Musik]
die creme kommt jetzt kurze den
kühlschrank und jetzt könnt ihr die
erdbeeren entweder vierteln oder achteln
oder auch in würfel schneiden
ich glaube ich achte jetzt kurz sind sie
nämlich keine
[Musik]
dann kann ich jetzt als nächstes den
tortenboden herauslösen
das ist auch schön kalt dann hatte ich
jetzt auch ganz kurz noch einen
kühlschrank kann mir dass ich besser
schneiden lässt
[Musik]
stützen und das backpapier abstimmen und
ich werde ihn jetzt zweimal
durchschneiden
dann habe ich drei bilden
[Musik]
kann ich die torte füllen unternehme ich
meist den torten deckel einfach
umgedreht damit ich später den geraden
boden als decken habe also die glatte
fläche habe und ich arbeite jetzt auch
gleich meine tortenring direkt außen
herum dann kommt ihr ziel etwas creme
rein
die wird glatt verstrichen
[Musik]
darauf gebe ich jetzt die hälfte der
erdbeeren
[Musik]
bis hin zum abdecken wenn ihr möchtet
dass die torte auch noch zwei drei tage
frisch ist dann macht lieber eine frucht
einlage stadt frischen erdbeeren hier
rein also dann kocht die erdbeeren ein
macht eine frucht einlage denn diese
erdbeeren werden jetzt morgen spätestens
übermorgen werden die matschig und mit
frucht einlagen habt ihr sie einfach
noch länger frisch aber dabei die jetzt
sowieso was sofort zu erzählen werden
nämlich für shared wird jetzt den
mittleren boden rein dann das gleiche
spiel also etwas creme die restlichen
erdbeeren wunsch dann den deckel drauf
[Musik]
ich habe eine fülle jemand darauf achten
dass ihr die creme so glatt wie möglich
streicht das heißt jetzt keinen google
bilden
ansonsten hat die torte später auch in
europa ich gucke dann schauen was sich
die erdbeeren so ein bisschen reindrückt
integrieren und dann gleicht sich das
nämlich richtig schön aus jetzt den
deckel drauf geben
[Musik]
und jetzt nehme ich einfach mit orten
retter zum abdecken
so bekommt sie keine schlechten gerüche
im kühlschrank die übrige creme die
packe ich jetzt auch noch ab und jetzt
kommt die torte für mindestens drei
stunden in den kühlschrank und dann
können wir so weiter dekorieren ich hier
noch die krümelchen weg fertig gestern
wurde die zu spät und ich hab die torte
nicht mehr fertig gemacht heute stelle
ich selber fertig wie gesagt er warte
jetzt über nach dem kühlschrank die
creme war auch über nacht im kühlschrank
beides schön abgedeckt und jetzt kann
ich die torte fertig dekorieren erstmal
löse ich sie hier raus dann gäste
einfach noch so viel gegrillt und so
viel gedreht dass die torte nicht mehr
fertig wurde
aber ist nicht schlimm das ist jetzt gut
durchgeführt gibt heute gut und jetzt
wird sie am rand schön glatt gestrichen
ihr könnt das jetzt entweder so machen
mit einer palette ich zeigt sich aber
auch einmal mit den boards denn damit
geht auch mega einfach aber wartet
zuerst werde ich den rand ein bisschen
einstreichen so die erste schicht
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich hier so eine garage bord
was etwas größer ist das heißt 25 cm
durchmesser kurz die torte stürzen
[Musik]
damit es nicht rutscht und jetzt hab ich
hier zwei garagen boards und schaue
jetzt dass du schön übereinander liegen
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich hier einfach die creme
nehmen und zwischen streichen und dann
wird sie nämlich gleich schön glatt
deswegen gibt auf jeden fall genug creme
auch auf dass sie den rand schön glatt
bekommt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn ihr jetzt den kompletten rand
eingestrichen habt könnt ihr eine
tankkarte nehmen oder eben die palette
und das ganze jetzt hier abziehen
und dafür ist jetzt eben das garagen
bord praktisch eins oben 1 unten
sozusagen als abgrenzung
das habe ich den rand schon mal glatt
schau doch mal ob irgendwo was fehlt so
wie hier ein kleines stückchen und dann
nochmal ab 10 und fertig stellen die
torte jetzt kurz in den kühlschrank dann
mittig ein body cream jetzt nicht
zerstöre ich glaube ich stelle es direkt
mit der tortenplatte sofort eine halbe
stunde und kann dann noch mal die
restliche grebe den kühlschrank stellen
damit nämlich noch die oberfläche
geglättet jetzt kann ich das obere der
sport wegnehmen
ganz vorsichtig ich will den rand nicht
zerstören
[Musik]
und jetzt hier noch die oberfläche schön
glätten mit der creme
ich habe übrigens noch ein bisschen
creme gemacht also ich schreibe ich dann
auch die veränderte menge in cap bzw auf
den block denn dann habt ihr auch
genügend creme zum bestreichen jetzt
hier schön von innen nach außen mit der
palette
[Musik]
jetzt guckt mich erstmal dass ich die
oberfläche schön glatt bekomme und dann
gehe ich noch einmal an den rand und
fertig
[Musik]
jetzt nehmt ihr die kleine palette und
streicht praktisch den überschuss von
außen nach innen hand
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das passt da kommt ja noch dicker drauf
also schon die torte machten kurz ins
gefrierfach und ich kann schon mal die
schokosoße herstellen denn das sollen
der trip torte werden und die restliche
creme völlig schon mal in einem
spritzbeutel ein für den job also für
die schokosoße verwende ich jetzt sahne
etwas kokosfett und dunkle schokolade da
habe ich jetzt netzanbieter kuvertüre
ich kann jetzt hier die sahne schon
einmal aufkochen lassen und solche trips
sind immer am einfachsten wenn man sie
auf eine buttercremetorte macht oder auf
eine karte auf einer quarkcreme ist ein
bisschen schwierig daher habe ich jetzt
die torte eingefroren damit die creme
einfach schön fest wird und durch das
herunter trocken der ganache nicht
mitunter fließt das er so die
schwierigkeit bei tripp cakes wollte ich
euch noch mal kurz sagen
quaid playing games with my heart wenn
die sahne kocht dann schaltet ihr denn
herr peter aus
dann kommt rein das sorgt für den
schönen glanz dann dekorateure und jetzt
einfach schön rühren wunderbar und die
garage die könnt ihr dann gleich
entweder mit einem löffel über die torte
tröpfeln oder mit einem spritzbeutel
oder mit so einem kleinen fläschchen
ich zeige euch das gleich mit einem
fläschchen aber ich lasse sie einen ganz
kurzen moment abkühlen
wie eine katze marke ist es mal mit
katzenmilch am besten machen
sie spielen mit wollknäuel da machen wir
so mit ihren tatzen mit farben und die
stützen sie sich immer die nase wo ja
und dann trauen sie sich seit den rücken
somit ihren tatzen katzen katzen und
dann kitzeln sie sich von katzen auf
hühnerkacke
[Musik]
das habe ich den grip hier in der
flasche gefüllt und am besten probiert
ihr eben hat das macht die marke am
besten probiert ihn auf eine rückseite
aus op wenn ihr ihn darüber fließen
lassen dann schön fest wird oder aber
vielleicht zu flüssig oder zu fest ist
also die tat ist jetzt schon kalt der
trip da ist noch lauwarm
muss er auch denn machen
[Musik]
das macht die gehört so herunter weiter
und wieder zugemacht
glaubst du das ist eine schöne torte zum
muttertag vielleicht ja jetzt gebe ich
hier ein bisschen noch in die mitte aber
gar nicht so viel also hier am rand
nicht in die mitte danke fürs
korrigieren
für den geschmack wollen wir hier auch
noch ein bisschen schokolade starb starb
statt mathe immer noch nicht ich nehme
nicht alles ich lass dir was übrig okay
ich weiß doch was du willst hatte
kürzlich schon jetzt eine palette aber
nicht anfassen ja
schon mal gemacht
geschmolzener schokolade ist angeblich
schokolade ja das habe ich mir fast
gedacht ja auch eingangs der feste
schokolade und schokosoße auf eis
wie willst du dann als eis essen
[Musik]
und die sind mit scratch für mich hier
ich wollte es noch dekorieren für dich
was wolltest du sagen meinte also
welches ausmachen
damals konnte zu einer eismaschine
sollte man etwas machen zusammen
wir machen mit denen ein bisschen
grimmig habe etwas merken gemacht in
spritzbeutel gefüllt mit rosetten thüle
hier vorne und damit liebe eller
dekoriere ich jetzt wird heute okay also
ich hier immer so kleine kringe
ja
[Musik]
ich will es auch gar nicht so
symmetrisch machen
[Musik]
und da nehme ich noch erdbeeren die
halbjährig jetzt gesetzt die noch mit
drauf ich glaube ohne grün heute
[Musik]
dann nehme ich nur bis den rosmarin aus
dem garten zu fuß essbare grün
[Musik]
na wer es kennt die ganze ab da die big
gemacht wow das war eine idee aber dann
habe ich einen kompletten ja aber dann
habe ich ein problem und zwar kann ich
dann die torte nicht mehr so schön
anschneiden
[Musik]
backen mit kindern höher auf villa das
ist eklig ok meine torte kommt jetzt
noch ein bisschen in die kühlung und
dann kümmere ich mich um diese kleine
torte und dann können über die torte
probieren und ich glaube das ist eine
region die hier und ich glaube dass eine
richtig hübsche muttertags torte die ihr
zubereiten können ohne viel
schnickschnack und trotzdem wunderschön
dekoriert naja ich klingt immer vor
airline sicherheit
[Musik]
ok murat kommen wir probieren der
muttertags torte so denn ich bin mutter
und du bist mein mann genau sie cool aus
natürlich ein tipp bei cryptic sagt
natürlich gibt es nicht gibt s nicht
regel ob er sich daran halten möchte
oder nicht ist euch überlassen
der club darf niemals unten ankommen ja
was denn doch und wenn doch finde ich es
auch nicht schlimm gar recht auf jeden
fall muss ankommt und dann cool aus ich
mag der creme und ich glaub ist es die
rpk ministers machst du etwas ganz neues
mit frischkäse eingekochten erdbeeren
riecht lecker schmeckt so richtig
joghurt lastig und das coole ist
natürlich auch hier thierstein
tortenstücke rosmarin passe ich genial
aufpoppen gibt in der optik cool ich
probiere manche sagen
rosmarin manche sagen rosmarin sag mal
was draus schmeckst schokolade und
erdbeer und tanker wanka will passt
schon gut und du hast den wohnraum
gebaut dass sein mandant verkohlte polit
hatte zwei sachen damit ja weg ganz
genial macht sie nach erdberg jetzt
momentan kaufte personal beim parametern
unterstützt eure region euren bauern in
eurer nähe kauf die erbauer haben gerade
eine schwierige zeit hinter sich und
unterstützt so einfach ganz ganz ernst
ich mach das bitte
und das nächste jetzt was etwas
persönliches meine mutter ist leider
nicht da die türkei und ich kann hier
kann es gerade nur anrufen kann sonst
besuchen und meine mutter grüßend ganz
ganz lieb und zu diesem tag alles alles
liebe und ich hoffe ich kann dich bald
wieder besuchen
pass auf nicht auf
ja ja alles liebe euch einen schönen mit
allen anbietern an alle mamas sollte
alles papas unterstützt den mamas
unterschätzt ihre arbeit nicht ja denn
mamas leisten ganz schön viel
alles alles liebe euch also guten tagen
wirklich gerade jetzt ganz ganz wichtig
naja ok kinder großziehen ist nicht so
einfach macht's gut macht's besser wo
ich bin ganz ruhig und ich hab dir
gestern gefüllt aber das merkt macht
keinen unterschied merkt man gar nicht
mehr gut schön durchgezogen
die besten erdbeere die heimischen wirte
und jetzt bringen wir mama und papa
wir haben dort stellen uns vor die tür
[Musik]
papa ist kenne vetter erdbeere
nur ein bisschen auch ich ja und zeigt
mal welche bin ich bin ich die dicke
erdbeere die dünne die bin ich auch
danke und papa warum
[Musik]
okay ich habe nichts damit zu tun dass
die post gehört
[Musik]